cambodge les propositions de la france à
l'onu dans ce journal un document
exceptionnel sur le cambodge iran après
le chalet d'iraniens demande maintenant
l'extradition de chapour bakhtiar les
légistes cars distinct chez lui en
auvergne deux jours de réflexion loin
des remous politiques là messieurs
bonsoir un journal un peu plus longue
qu'à l'habitude car nous sommes ce soir
en possession d'un document
impressionnant que nous ont apporté du
cambodge gérard ce bac et jean-françois
renoux et que vous verrez à la fin de ce
journal vers 20h20 notre équipe s'est
enfoncé 13 à l'intérieur du pays et
confirmera ce que le monde entier
murmurait le cambodge est à l'abandon
son peuple et à la dérive et ce cri
d'autres voile ont repris depuis cet
après midi la tribune des nations unies
car à new york on s'est enfin décidé à
prendre des mesures concrètes
la conférence qui s'est ouverte ce matin
a pour but de contribuer à un programme
de secours d'urgence à la population
cambodgienne
premier orateur à s'exprimer tout à
l'heure ce jean françois poncet le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères nous l'écoutons
le peuple français a ressenti
intensément le drame qui accable le
peuple paie mais ce peuple que nous
savons pacifique et qui a donné au monde
une des civilisations les plus raffinés
qui choix à une histoire longue qui nous
lie à lui nous n'avons jamais connu dans
nos relations mutuelles l'indifférence
et encore moins l'hostilité
aujourd'hui nous voulons prendre part
dans l'effort commun pour sauver ce
peuple avant de lui donner la chance de
revivre voilà pourquoi mon pays a eu à
coeur de provoquer cette conférence et
aspire ardemment à son succès
le gold american son côté a annoncé
qu'il ferait tout pour aider ce peuple
et je vous invite donc à nous retrouver
à la fin de ce journal pour un très long
et un très beau reportage tourné sur
place
deuxième préoccupation des américains ce
soir l'occupation de leur ambassade à
téhéran l'affairé grave même si
washington c'est tout pour les minimiser
tout en ajoutant qu'il n'était pas
question un instant que les états unis
cède aux extrémistes iraniens qui
réclament toujours vous le savez
l'extradition du shah hospitalisé à new
york
les choses sont même allés encore plus
loin aujourd'hui puisque les étudiants
s'en sont pris à l'ambassade de grande
bretagne ils l'ont occupé pour réclamer
cette fois l'extradition de chapour
bakhtiar qui d'ailleurs ne se trouve pas
en angleterre
le gouvernement britannique a
vigoureusement protesté contre
l'occupation de son ambassade occupation
qui viennent ccn str4 après l'ambassade
des états unis est toujours j'occupais
officiellement les étudiants qu'ils
retiennent en otage 59 personnes exigent
expulsion du chat qui se trouve
actuellement hospitalisé à new york ils
demandent aussi la rupture des relations
diplomatiques avec les américains au nom
de l'ayatollah khomeini il exige sa cage
manifeste promet ni de son côté ouvre
d'injures les britanniques lendemain
d'extrader l'ancien
ministre chapour bakhtiar londres en
réponse ce dernier n'est pas en grande
bretagne protège pendant ce temps-là
l'ambassade de grande bretagne et à son
tour occupé sans prise d'otages et puis
en province sont également occupés de
consulats américains
ce soir donc les américains viennent de
faire savoir qu'il ne serait pas au
chantage
le char restera à nuire et pendant ce
temps-là 59 personnes sont retenus en
otage en principe leur vie ne serait pas
menacée mais toute cette opération est
le prétexte au déclenchement d'une
grande campagne anti américain le
gouvernement iranien laisse faire il
s'agit maintenant de savoir coup franc
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que en
frappant directement deux des
principales capitales occidentales
l'ayatollah khomeiny qui a soutenu les
étudiants veut nous rappeler un petit
peu comme du ce le fait que l'occident
reste terriblement dépendant de son pays
il le tient je puis dire par la pompe
cela fait maintenant un an que les
événements d'hier en font peser une
menace constante sur les
approvisionnements en pétrole non
seulement des états unis mais aussi de
l'ensemble du pays du monde occidental
l'iran exporte actuellement l'équivalent
de 150 à 200 millions de tonnes de
pétrole par an c'est moins qu'à l'époque
du shah mais cela représente quand même
une fois et demie à deux fois la
consommation annuelle d'un pays comme la
france c'est déjà la fermeture du
robinet iranien qui a déclenché la
succession des hausses de prix de cette
année et par rapport à l'an passé à la
même époque le prix du pétrole a
pratiquement doublé
certains religieux iraniens certains
ayatollahs sont partisans de faire du
pétrole une arme politique pour amener
américains et européens à plus de
souplesse à l'égard du problème
palestinien
le pétrole iranien représente moins de
10% des approvisionnements français
mais si l'iran décidé de nouvelles
restrictions l'hiver 1979 serait très
rude hélas dès 1980 très difficile iran
est en effet toujours le deuxième
exportateur mondial de pétrole et peut
ainsi déclencher une nouvelle crise
pétrolière inca nationale est ce même
chapitre j'ajouterai que le nigeria son
tour a décidé d'augmenter de 11% le prix
de son pétrole qui dépasse ainsi le prix
plafond fixé par l'opep lors de sa
dernière
ça m'arrive maintenant aux affaires
françaises qui depuis quelques jours
suivre leurs cours dans un bien curieux
clim
alors est-ce pour prendre du champ s
comme on l'a dit pour sentir battre le
pouls de ce qu'on appelle la france
profonde
est ce pour préparer des décisions
d'importance toujours est il que le
prime république et ce soir dans un
endroit inhabituel un lundi fans à sa
propriété d'auvergne il a présidé tout à
l'heure un déjeuner organisé par les
maires du canton d'orange sport montagne
dont il a été lui-même conseiller
général avant son élection à l'elysée
rien ne remplace le contact direct
sylvie je verrai beaucoup de personnes
pendant deux jours en auvergne pour
étudier avec elle leurs éléments de
confiance et leur inquiétude à son
retour mercredi donc le chef de l'état
déjeunera en tête à tête avec raymond
barre à l'issue du conseil des ministres
et il paraît difficile d'imaginer que
les deux hommes n'évoque pas les suite
de la mort de robert boulin qui a encore
connu aujourd'hui de nouveaux
développements le rpr qui s'étaient
réunis ce matin en effet décidé
d'attaquer l'un de nos confrères de rtl
en diffamation philippe alexandre avait
laissé entendre que c'était ce parti qui
était à l'origine des fuites de
l'instruction fûtes délibérément
organisées au cours d'une réunion tenue
à la mi septembre au siège du mouvement
c'est faux dit ce soir mais un harpon ce
numéro deux du rpr qui se dit écoeuré du
développement telle campagne
nous l'écoutons je veux redire que je
suis profondément écoeuré je suis
écoeuré par les procédés que je vois
depuis ce matin et je dois dire que si
j'ai décidé d'assigner un journaliste en
diffamation c'est parce que j'estime que
nous avons été diffamé et je crois que
il appartient maintenant à la justice
qui est saisi de cette affaire de dire
où est la vérité
quel est intérêt politique contre non
seulement à partir du moment où une
formation politique comme la nôtre est
attaqué comme elle lady a certainement
des intérêts possible attaque
écoutez c'est la justice qui le dira
bien la france dans ces lettres robert
boulin se plaint de la collusion de
certains milieux politiques et même de
ses propres amis alors si je comprends
bien ce soir vous est affirmatif il ne
peut s'agir en aucun cas d'un ou de
plusieurs membres du rpr il ne peut
s'agir en aucun cas dans ou de plusieurs
membres du rpr
je suis très nette à cet égard et je
tiens à le préciser de manière formelle
je pense qu'en dehors des instances
officielles du rpr est ce qu'il ne peut
pas se faire qu'un responsable de votre
parti à votre insu et pris des contacts
qui amplifiaient affaire boulin et
peut-être monsieur boulet a laissé une
lettre qu'il a adressée l' agence
france-presse
où il met en cause nommément un certain
nombre de personnes
je dois dire que s'il avait eu une
attention particulière contre un membre
du rassemblement pour la république
il n'aurait pas hésité une seconde
certainement le nommer philippe
alexandre de son côté maintient
intégralement ses déclarations de samedi
je n'ai pas été le seul à qui ses
confidences ont été fait dit il
alors mes copains laissons de côté
provisoirement en tout cas l'aspect jory
des choses pour essayer de nous
intéresser à ces développements
politiques ses prolongements qui ne
cesse de nous étonner mais oui
aujourd'hui que vous l'avais dit c'était
donc la journée de la contre attaque du
rpr une contre attaque rigoureuse comme
dès hier soir d'ailleurs nous le
laissions entendre et j'ai noté que le
rpr réalise et en particulier à deux
points que nous avions été amenés évoqué
parce qu'il paraissait de points
effectivement important de tout est de
toute cette affaire il avait d'abord cet
article de philippe alexandre que vous
venez d'évoquer vous avez évoqué aussi
et sa réponse et puis l'autre point
c'était les confidences que disait ton
monsieur robert boulin lui-même avait
fait un monsieur maurice plantier
secrétaire d'état aux anciens
combattants et qui mettait en cause
également le rpr s'est expliqué et a
publié aujourd'hui une mise au point
une mise au point qui n'est pas
exactement un démenti mais enfin qui
propose de dire qu'il n'ya pas eu de
déclaration publique sur cet aspect
exactement bien alors on a l'impression
aujourd'hui encore que de la presse est
montré comme bouc émissaire
louis et les hommes les hommes
politiques dans toute cette affaire ont
un peu tendance à accuser la presse mais
je pense que si les hommes politiques et
les journalistes avaient le temps de
méditer il pourrait peut-être méditer
cette leçon que donne toute cette
affaire ce qu'il faut se méfier des
rumeurs
or si le ce sont les journalistes qui
rende publiques les rumeurs il faut bien
dire qu est la source de ces rumeurs
dans la plupart des cas ce sont des
hommes politiques et si les hommes
politiques reprochent aux journalistes
ce qu'ils écrivent
est ce qu'ils disent eh bien je pense
qu'il peut être permis aux journalistes
de dire aux hommes politiques
et dans toute cette affaire ils ont
peut-être parler à la fois trop et trop
peu ils ont parlé trop sur le ton de la
confidence et peut-être ne se
manifeste-t-il pas assez de façon
publique
en tout cas on peut dire que chaque jour
depuis le début de cette affaire on
trouve un nouveau coup pas pratique et
bien oui on a l'impression que
finalement chacun seraient bien contents
de trouver un bouc émissaire dans un
premier temps lorsqu'il était encore
vivant lorsque la rumeur a commencé à se
répandre de ramatuelle à paris on a bien
eu l'impression que c'était robert
boulin qui serait ce bouc émissaire
quand on a appris sa mort c'est la
presse qu'est devenu le bouc émissaire
quand on a connu les le texte des
déclarations des lettres de robert
boulin eh bien c'est la justice et même
un moment le garde des sceaux qui ont
fait figure de bouc émissaire maintenant
après un quelques jours d'insinuations
et de rumeurs c'est le rpr qui se
retrouvent ou qui a failli se retrouver
le bouc émissaire dans ce climat qui est
alourdi par cette affaire mais qui était
déjà lourd dans cette ambiance malsaine
a l'impression que chacun serait soulagé
de trouver un coupable et un seul
coupable
la vérité est sans doute plus complexe
il serait bon que la justice qui est
chargé de découvrir cette vérité puisse
la rechercher sans passion mais quand on
voit tout ce qui passe tout ce qui se
passe ces jours ci n'est ce pas demander
un peu l'impossible l'erea social
maintenant la situation chez alstom
atlantique toujours bloqué une réunion
de la commission de conciliation s'est
soldée hier par un nouvel échec ce même
terminé par des heures d'échauffourées
chez ducelier maintenant dans la
haute-loire évacuation cette nuit par
les forces de police de luz inoccupés
agro mesnil le quart des effectifs a
repris le travail ce matin
enfin grenoble les ouvriers des
établissements merlin guérin schirrhein
pardon ont également repris le travail
ce matin les résultats des négociations
ont été jugés positifs par l'ensemble
des syndicats
les saisies arrêts saisi par l'inflation
si je puis dire les salariés qui ne
veulent pas payer impôts et pensions
alimentaires vont voir leur saisie arrêt
sur salaire grimper de 50 %
consistoire extraordinaire à rome c'est
la première fois en dehors de l'élection
d'un pape que les cardinaux se
réunissaient il était centré ce matin
rome a assisté d'abord à une messe à la
mémoire des cardinaux morts cette année
on évoquera à huit clos plusieurs
dossiers délicats à commencer sans doute
par les finances de l'église qui ne sont
guère brillantes et d'une manière
générale le gouvernement de jean
françois 6
il est exceptionnel parce que il ya très
longtemps que les cardinaux n'ont jamais
été réunies de cette façon ils sont
réunis strictement que pour l'élection
du pape alors ils ont beaucoup travaillé
l'an dernier pour les deux papes
mais là maintenant on dirait que le pape
veut faire de l'assemblée des cardinaux
en tant que tel un instrument de
gouvernement avec lui quel sujet va-t-il
aborder
on ne sait pas bien on pense et je crois
qu'on peut dire que y'a question des
votes des finances du vatican qui va
être abordé la question des vocations
mais surtout la véritable question
s'avère justement quel sera le mode de
gouvernement de l'actuel pape jean paul
ii jusque maintenant
il semblait avec le pape paul 6 que sa
lettre le synode le synode c'est à dire
des évêques venant du monde entier élu
par les autres évêques et gouvernants
avec le pape et il semble maintenant que
le pape veut faire deux assemblées
l'assemblée donc de ces évêques le
synode et l'assemblée des cardinaux de
temps en temps alors on va voir
justement dans les semaines qui suivent
est surtout dans les mois et les années
qui vont suivre avec qui le pape va
surtout gouverner avec ce sénat que sont
les cardinaux ou bien cette chambre de
députés et le synode ou les deux en même
temps on ne sait pas quelles peuvent
être les conséquences
les conséquences seraient ou bien une
très grande centralisation si c'est
uniquement avec les cardinaux et quelque
chose à ses conservateurs ou au
contraire une décentralisation
si c'est avec le synode c'est-à-dire
avec l'assemblée des évêques élus par
leurs pairs élus par les évêques du
monde entier tchécoslovaquie libération
de cinq signataires de la charte des 77
il était soupçonné de vouloir détruire
un édifice public de prague quatre de
leurs camarades arrêtés il ya trois
jours sont toujours sous les verrous
italie jan fabre président du parti
radical italien de nationalité française
jan fabre vous le savez incarcéré ce
matin la prison de fer de fresnes pour
insoumission
il était jusqu alors secrétaire général
de son parti en italie
la cote de ted kennedy en légère baisse
49% le vecteur américain lui font
confiance dit l'hebdomadaire time contre
39% à jimmy carter qui lui remonte
les députés espagnols et le haschisch
plusieurs d'entre eux notamment numéro
deux du parti socialiste
avouant fumée et demande la légalisation
des drogues douces et puis maintenant la
controverse autour des raid équestre je
vous le disais la semaine dernière
serait désormais interdit à la suite de
la mort de trois chevaux à florac en
l'or en lozère pardon et bien cette
interdiction
malgré cela mme action arrêt des cas
s'est déroulée hier dans le lot à vous
voilà et vous venez certainement pour
filmer les chevaux morts cette phrase
nous l'avons entendu trois quatre cinq
fois et dès notre arrivée à montcuq en
quercy petit village du lot
l'accident de florac est encore dans
toutes les bouches le petit monde de la
course d'endurance est salie par le
geste de quelques tueurs de chevaux
cette semaine le ministère de
l'agriculture interdit la course de
montcuq les organisateurs s'enflamme
c'est un règlement de comptes distille
en fait voilà l'histoire
soucieux de ménager son autonomie le
comité national des raid équestre a
tourné le dos voilà quelque temps au
haras nationaux financier de l'élevage
ainsi qu'à la fédération responsable des
disciplines des caisses
résultat les organismes officiels
reconnaissent second comité dépourvu les
compétences du précédent est coupable
des erreurs commises
pourtant malgré menacé interdiction la
course a bien lieu oui parce qu'on
essaye depuis trois ans de montrer
qu'avec des contrôles vétérinaires
sérieux comme celui que vous êtes en
train de voir maintenant avec une
éducation du cavadee on peut arriver
justement à cette performance sans
problème pour les chevaux vous jouez
gros aujourd'hui
non on fait comme d'habitude ça fait
trois ans qu'on contrôle des épreuves on
continue on a été violemment attaqué au
point de vue endurance mais en tout cas
pas en tant que comité national des
rêves et quelle ambiance
les gens nous connaissent pour notre
sérieux voyez aujourd'hui professeur
lescure de toulouse qui est venu nous
aider vous avez des grands spécialistes
du cheval qui viennent travailler avec
nous parce qu'ils savent qu'on travaille
pour le cheval et non pas contre lui
électrocardiogramme température presque
le bilan de santé est conforme pour les
50 chevaux autorise à partir première
épreuve 80 km de circuit en trois étapes
avec contrôle vétérinaire et
récupération à chaque arrivée là chez le
cheval retrouve sa véritable vocation
courir dans la campagne et on scelle la
responsabilité du cavalier et entière
connaître son cheval plus imposer un
train régulier et doser ses efforts
avant le ravitaillement fournies par le
suiveur cheval cavalier suiveurs 3 pour
gagner une course 80 km à 20 de moyenne
pour les meilleurs fractionnée entre au
galop et même course à pied aux côtés du
cheval une façon d'apporter sa
contribution à l'effort
un effort que 25 chevaux c'est à dire la
moitié seront autorisés à reconduire le
lendemain toujours sur 80 kg mais
subissent encore un électrocardiogramme
et alors on mesure le rythme cardiaque
le rythme respiratoire et si il y à une
version 6 l'inversion de ce rythme
durant encore au bout de 20 minutes ils
sont éliminés de la course
comme promis donc maintenant notre page
spéciale sur le cambodge je vous le
disais en début de journal le monde
entier et est interpellé aujourd'hui par
la conférence extraordinaire des nations
unies consacré ce drame pour sa part le
gouvernement français va organiser une
campagne nationale de collecte au profit
des populations du cambodge campagne qui
se déroulera parallèlement à l'aide de
humanitaire d'urgence décidées par paris
d'autres initiatives individuelles sont
à noter par exemple celle ci qui
viennent des employés d'une société de
transport d'alsace relayée par le pdg de
l'entreprise qui refuse de dire son nom
l'association terre des hommes et le
quotidien l'alsace c'est bien toutes ses
volontés réunis ont permis de trouver 70
tonnes de couvertures de produits
alimentaires et de matériels médicaux
un boeing 747 partira la semaine
prochaine de mulhouse est un geste
magnifique gaccio mais qui joue la sueur
ne sera pas trop pour aider une
population en détresse
gérard ce bague et jean-françois renou
ont vécu avec eux pendant deux semaines
ils ont pénétré au cambodge avec ce que
l'on appelle la troisième fort c'est à
dire avec ceux qui sont à la fois
hostile aux khmers rouges de l'ancien
régime polpot qui continuent à se battre
de leur côté au style aussi au régime
mis en place par les vietnamiens et
c'est ce régime qui aujourd'hui est le
plus décrié par les cambodgiens que nos
reporters ont pu rencontrer
e
où
un tourbillon où se mêlent la poussière
la peur et la fin jeter sur le chemin de
l'exode
ils sont des milliers à l'intérieur de
leur propre pays
ils fuient la guerre et surtout la
famille dès les premiers kilomètres à
l'intérieur du cambodge
on découvre tout un club une foule en
marche un long et lent chemin pour
survivre
et
bras s'est brisé à l'ecoute de l'écho de
la fin ils suivent la rumeur qui leur a
dit que le chemin des points de ce court
où il se précipite
pour cette distribution contrôlée par le
front de libération du peuple mais les
cambodgiens nationaliste le riz est
gratuit mais il n'en est pas de même
partout
les trafiquants et le marché noir
arracha c'est malheureux les quelques
biens qu'ils ont pu sauver du cauchemar
de pol pot
au bout de leurs peines ces quelques
gamelles de riz
oui
il arrive
là
comme deux jours vous avez mis pour
venir jusqu'ici de marche à pied papier
seulement
oui comme de jour peut-être 30 jours à
phnom penh d'ici 30 jours sur la route
beaucoup d'éléphants défense ont faim et
sont mois les petits ce sont les potées
ce malade son jeu malade il n'ya pas
laurie il n'ya pas les médicaments
il n'ya pas les vêtements aussi là et
les vietnamiens alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
font vous avez vu l'armée vietnamienne
j'ai vu beaucoup le 28 janvier pendant
l'heure les peuples qui m a beaucoup d
loridan internet a aussi levé dernière
son arrêté ne donne pas le riz il admire
les ennemis ilan et les les pubs autres
hommes les jeunes familles c'est juste
c'est vrai monsieur
non
cette femme avec son bébé balade à fait
comme beaucoup d'autres des dizaines de
kilomètres pour une poignée de riz le
régime des khmers rouges portant premier
la responsabilité de cette misère une
population exterminer une exploitation
agricole anarchique
le critère n'était pas le rendement mais
l'humiliation pour ce qui devait
racheter leur faut la faute principale
être un intellectuel c'est à dire avoir
dépassé le stade de l'école pris mais
j'ai été frappé par la haine qu'ils
avaient un aléa de nous et des autres
qui étaient d innocence alors il y les
cuisines ce qui est estimé ce qu'ils
estimaient comme en grèce dangereux
dangereux c'est sain et pendant votre
captivité pas ce qu'on peut appeler cela
de la captivité je vieillissais de la
captivité et pendant ma captivité c'est
pendant toute la durée de ma captivité
c'est la méchanceté la nullité des
régimes et surtout l'absence de la
liberté on peut pas parler on peut pas
discuter on ne peut pas demander des
explications ne pouviez pas parler c'est
à dire c'est à dire même entre nos
grandes entreprises honnêtes vous venez
au travail
il faut travailler silencieusement alors
si on discute
sinon on parle il pourrait nous taxer
faire des six nations
et alors et alors c'est le massacre
c'est à dire que pendant quatre ans de
votre captivité vous n'avez pratiquement
pas parlé très peu un peu c'est à dire
combien de mots par jour
ouf vous dit bonne et manger ça y est
c'est fini je vais au travail je me
repose c'est tout c'est tout pendant
toute une journée c'était un seul mot
que vous prononcez l'esa est ce que vous
n'avez pas perdu à ce moment là votre
capacité intellectuelle beaucoup et ça
se voit vous voyez
les pillards plus d'autorité l'anarchie
pour se déplacer dans une relative
sécurité il faut se joindre à ces
colonnes de réfugiés se fondre dans la
foule est toujours ce tourbillon
inlassable se heurtant aux différentes
armées qui continue à faire la guerre au
milieu de ce fourmillement de miséreux
dans plusieurs parties du territoire des
soldats des troupes en armes
il ya bien sûr encore des khmers rouges
mais de plus en plus ce que l'on appelle
des khmers serei c'est à dire des
nationalistes anti khmers rouges et anti
vietnamien le front national pour la
libération et sans doute l'organisation
la plus sérieuse il opère profondément à
l'intérieur du pays
nous avons parcouru avec eux près de 150
km le responsable militaire du front est
un général qui a gagné ses galons à
l'époque de lon nol s'est enfui à la
chute de phnom penh a vécu deux ans aux
états unis pour ensuite ouvrir une
épicerie dans le 15e arrondissement a
peint depuis un an il a tout abandonné
et se consacre à nouveau à l'art de la
guerre
gerald on a beaucoup parlé des généraux
corrompus de l'époque de lon nol oui il
y en a moi même je suis pas tout à fait
propre mais je suis quand même le mental
vous n'étiez peut être l'un des moins
sale mais est ce que aujourd'hui votre
crédibilité et peut être valable j'ai
quoi oui pour quelle raison parce que
voyez et en avant 75 je suis le mental
est quand même je suis un des
prestigieux commandant les divisions
c'est dire le meilleur général coma
temps nous avons maintenant les poissons
dans l'eau nous sommes une force
montante
la quasi totalité de la population est
de notre côté
les khmers rouges étaient nos ennemis
mais maintenant ce sont les vietnamiens
nos ennemis morts
après deux jours de marche forcée le
général dean del entre dans ce village
il est situé à 2 km détente de benty czm
à nort des temples d'angkor
le but de notre marche étaient ces
temples de benty de chemin mais un
bataillon vietnamiens s'y étaient
installés quelques heures avant notre
arrivée pour éviter l'affrontement
direct le général et ses troupes ne
resteront que quelques minutes le temps
de rassembler la population tenir un
discours politique demandé de ne pas
coopérer avec les vietnamiens
et de nouveau la troupe reprend sa
marche et se fond dans la brousse
contrôle des populations et action
psychologique opérations classiques de
la guérilla une haine séculaire existe
entre les peuples vietnamien et
cambodgien déjà la france était
intervenue en indochine au 19e siècle
pour empêcher le vietnam d'avaler le
cambodge 18 division près de deux cent
mille soldats vietnamiens soutiennent le
régime installé à phnom penh à la chute
des khmers rouges
après le laos le cambodge sous l' aile
protectrice des vietnamiens le vieux
rêve de chi minh se réalisera enfin une
grande indochine unis et vietnamienne et
comment se comportent les vietnamiens
avec elle ils demandent si les
villageois de n'organiser étrangers des
banques heures pour des fonds sa troupe
pour les gens pour les hommes sont
restés sur place
les vietnamiens ne les autorisent pas à
sortir du canadien n'a absolument pas
les jambes
nous sommes arrivés aux premières
fraudes le pkk est de 67 ans km 500 delà
du village que l'événement ya s'installe
notre position a tellement ce matin les
vitres
voilà notre poste de sonnettes puis en
n'accrochant vernet le mot bennahmias
vrai nom du village mais
résultat de cet accrochage trois blessés
dont un grave
chez les cambodgiens pertes vietnamienne
inconnu oui c'est pas grâce avec les ob
sais pas et qu'est ce que ça fait quand
même fait qu'est ce que ça leur fait
comme effet de magalas la salle on
tourne la tête
oui hélas aussi des vomissements
telle une ombre la foule continue
d'avancer avec un seul but précis la
poignée de riz
comment expliquer que les vietnamiens
refuse jusqu'à présent que l'aide
internationale atteignent véritablement
le fond des campagnes sans doute l'une
des questions au coeur du débat aux
nations unies aux problèmes humanitaires
s'ajoutent les problèmes politiques qui
est le gouvernement légal du cambodge
déchirer les différents mouvements
cambodgiens sont eux mêmes divisés
le prince yanouk fait de la diplomatie
mais dans le pays
on sent une réticence à son égard il a
été un moment
l'allié des khmers rouges
comment vous situez-vous par rapport au
prince yanouk notre ancien no il faut le
reconnaître il nous a rendu beaucoup de
services dans le temps il a fait l'union
et il l'a fait la donne et la paix au
cambodge pendant 16 ans mais il faut
reconnaître c'est bien fait mais le
monde entier de quoi en ce moment un
l'habitude de penser en termes de
personnalité
or le problème qu'on retient ce n'est
plus en termes de personnalité qu'il
faut penser il faut pas penser en termes
de peuples qu'est-ce qui souffre
qu'est-ce qui meurt c'est le peuple
cambodgien vous avez vu vous avez vu
malheureux morin malin mais ce sont ces
peuples là qu'il faut consulter et qu'il
faut libérer et il faut demander leur
opinion
en attendant les armées de la troisième
force se gonfle avec un drapeau et une
discipline militaire
il ne s'agit plus de simples guérilleros
ce dans les monts cardamome sanctuaire
de forêts épaisses
ils tentent d'installer une véritable
administration mais leur tâche est
colossale
il faut certes contrôler les populations
mais aussi leur donner de quoi se
nourrit ce village est situé à 7 heures
de marche à pied pour les hommes valides
du point d'approvisionnement situé le
long de la frontière thaïlandaise est
ici médicaments et nourriture sont très
nettement insuffisant quel âge à son
enfant et comment le nourrit tél
par delà il est encore au sein
et bon mais la corogne à la farce et de
la firme à nous vendre les rayer de
clown parce que la sous tend notre mais
elle se soigne
ils auront comme le film il a la fièvre
aussi pour ceux qui n'ont plus la force
de marcher ce sera la mort lente
la fin la malaria les fièvres la
dysenterie
dans ce que l'on peut appeler un village
modèle tout est relatif un orphelinat a
été créé
les enfants qui ont perdu leurs parents
ont été regroupés et on essaie de les
sauver pourtant ils meurent de
malnutrition et l'épuisement les étés 60
ils ne sont plus que 30 en l'espace de
cinq mois ils sont morts de maladies et
de privations c'est ce qu'ils étaient
les prisonniers les forçats des khmers
rouges il devait tracer chaque jour
trois mètres cube de terre et le petit
10 et quelquefois quand il avait fini
leurs travaux
il devait recommencer encore le soir
qu'est ce qui leur donnait à manger
il avait pour tout repas du potage duris
avec du sel
il ya là en ce moment dans la forêt
encore des centaines qui erre et qui
essayent de survivre par leurs propres
moyens et vous n'essayez pas de les
recueillir
nous avons essayé mais ils mourront de
toute façon 15 ans et les city mais oui
l'appelle et lui la croissance dopée par
ces quatre de quatre années de privation
et c'est le gars de la majorité de ses
enfants tous le petit guillaume
corneille au mans 15 ans aussi le petit
je connais you man
il rappelle par son fils et son âge ils
ont besoin de quoi ces enfants en train
d'un contact avec la zone germanique
cela confirme avec la sotra independent
glissé dans sa baignoire
il voudra avoir de l'argent pour
s'acheter des gâteaux les gâteaux qu'ils
avaient l'habitude de manger des gâteaux
de riz
dans ces forêts profondes sur les
sentiers entre les guérilleros ce
circulent toute une population miséreuse
de véritable fantôme amaigri par la
privation
ils marchent inlassablement dans cette
jungle une jungle impressionnante où la
lumière ne pénètre pratiquement pas et
où les cris des animaux se répète
inlassablement
et
tous
certains restent d'autres tentent la
fuite il s'évade du cambodge
pourchassés par les khmers rouges et les
vietnamiens évitant les champs de mines
le long de la frontière rongé par la
faim et la fiève ils vont échouer dans
les camps de réfugiés de thaïlande le
camp de saké au 35000 personnes
s'entassent est ici
beaucoup viendront y mourir près de
vingt heures par jour
il ya déjà une petite phrase
partenariat oui
deux millions et demi de cambodgiens
sont morts sous le régime de pol pot tu
aujourd'hui deux autres millions sont en
sursis
et vous
m
elle sert de
un génocide qui nous en rappelle
d'autres et qui a donc enfin été évoquée
depuis cet après midi à la tribune des
nations unies
mesrine me terrorisait c'est ce que
vient de dire à la police un peu
incrédule le sylvie jeanjacquot l'ami du
gangster elle a également indiqué
qu'elle n'avait jamais participé à aucun
effet pour elle
telle une minute 20 secondes
hausse
pop
où ça
génocide qui nous en rappelle d'autres
et qui a donc enfin été évoquée depuis
cet après midi à la tribune des nations
unies
mesrine me terrorisait c'est ce que
vient de dire à la police un peu
incrédule le sylvie jeanjacquot l'ami du
gangster elle a également indiqué
qu'elle n'avait jamais participé à aucun
méfait pour elle la mort de mesrine
serait un soulagement
mesrine qui aurait envisagé plusieurs
enlèvements de personnalités parmi
lesquelles philippe bouvard et le prix
du premier roman a été attribué
aujourd'hui un marco koskas pour son
livre balas boulez et puis la météo
comme chaque fois un journal aujourd'hui
sur la plus grande partie du pays le
temps était vous le voyez doux et humide
sur les régions méditerranéennes
après une matinée ensoleillée quelques
pluies demain toujours sur les régions
méditerranéennes à temps ensoleillé
accompagné de mistral et tramontane mais
sur les autres régions vous le voyez
temps nuageux à très nuageux avec des
pluies intermittentes vos prochains
rendez vous avec la rédaction d'antenne
2 tout d'abord le magazine question de
temps présenté dans quelques minutes par
louis blériot consacré ce soir à
l'homosexualité
et puis vers 23h30 23h20 peut-être hervé
claude qui vous présentera les toutes
dernières informations
enfin demain le premier journal anglais
ne vous sera présentée par patrick
lecocq à 12h45
bonne soirée à tous